they're on the way up everyone hides of
pills brace yourselves you're about to
look into the face of pure evil
ah good morning good morning good
morning
I'm captain Julie Kim and I'm Chuck if
you want results stay the hell out of my
way okay
Wow I guess I know who the office badass
is anyway I just want to say how excited
I am to be here at the nine-nine I heard
the best things about this place from
who
madeline wuntch perchance oh I've
actually never spoken to acting
commissioner once I requested the
posting through the CEO P's office I
didn't prepare a speech but a little
about me I was the first female
asian-american captain in the NYPD my
guilty pleasure is charity work and what
do I do for fun well basically just
design and build skate parks former
July's communities and that's me what a
gigantic turd agreed an unformed pile no
she seemed kind of Awesome to me the
thing is she can't be awesome because
she's here to replace holt but she said
as soon as his urine uniform is finished
she's moving on that's a pretty generous
interpretation of what she said Amy as
soon as you're in uniform is finished
I'll be moving on okay fine it's exactly
what she said but she seems like a liar
someone told me she's a pill-popper papa
well she's not lying about her resume
did you know the rocks character in Fast
and the Furious was based on her Hobbes
or Shaw she's not a Hobbes or a Shaw if
anything she's a Trevor that's the guy
my mom dated after she divorced my dad
it's all about your daddy issues step
daddy issues this is a new thing I'm
complicated anyways
Trevor seemed perfect to you no he was
nice to my mom he drove a limousine he
would take us out to restaurants but
then my mom caught him cheating and we
never saw him again
so it turns out when people are too good
to be true they are that sucks Jake but
I don't think captain Kim czar Trevor oh
really
she could have had her choice of any
precinct why would she choose this lame
temporary posting here I'll tell you why
because madeline wuntch sent her so what
do we do I'm glad you asked you know how
captain Kim wants to have individual
meetings with us to assess our personal
strengths and help us achieve our goals
stupid bee I say we use those meetings
to figure out why she's really here she
may seem perfect but I guarantee you
there's a but and I'm gonna find that
butt and drill down on it come on man
you have to know how that sounds shut up
cool Charles I hate this new dynamic
and thanks for coming in first off do
you have any questions for me just want
why would someone of your pedigree
choose the nine-nine well why would you
choose to stay here as long as you have
this is my family a second family I have
a wife and three kids at home oh please
tell me you have pictures I may have one
two hard drives at my desk let me grab a
real fast it's okay so captain Kim I've
been going through your files I've been
going through yours very impressive
stuff not just the casework but look at
how they're organized the penmanship
color coding how do you get such
straight margins on a handwritten
documents oh well I like to say when it
comes to margins there's no margin for
error
so supposedly you build skate parks huh
what are your three favorite tricks Oh
ginger snap plasma spin roast beef grab
what about you Polly's and the roast
beef one that you said it doesn't matter
about skater so let's move on well I've
been looking through your recent
evaluations and I don't think you belong
here I knew it you want to get rid of me
well you know what you can't fire me
because I quit metaphorically
obviously for medical insurance reasons
it's much better if you do fire me I'm
not firing you
I'm very impressed by your talent and
record and it just so happens I have a
friend in the FBI who was looking for an
NYPD liaison officer so what do you say
so what did you say I told her I'd
rather stick my entire head inside a
giraffes long blonde but then accept a
job offer from her you said that in my
head in my mouth I said I would think
about it and get back to her she'll get
the message when I dilly-dally working
with the FBI that's your dream job Jay
first of all my dream job is spy falsely
accused of betraying his country forced
to work alone to clear his name by
taking down the mysterious organization
that framed him known only as shade
secondly it wasn't a real job offer
she's up to something
mmm maybe she's just a nice person I
mean she did seem genuinely interested
in my kids looked at any of you get a
straight answer from her about why she's
at the nine-nine hmm right me neither
but guess what I called the COP office
and they said the form to transfer her
here wasn't signed by them it was signed
by watch she lied mm-hmm just because
once signed an order doesn't mean they
know each other you wake up that woman
is a demon and it couldn't be more
obvious
oh here you are I have to say how great
it was talking to you all and I want to
let you know about a party I'm throwing
at my house tomorrow night are you
interested oh well we will think about
it and get back to you great just let me
know and now we dilly-dally
[Music]
you